I watched him repeat himself five times
four weeks ago I saw you review so far
as a belkin to go
I mean first of all this guy's a choke
artist and this guy's a liar you don't
have the endorsement of one Republican
senator and you work with these dinner
cruise you should be ashamed of yourself
if you're really getting beaten badly I
know you're embarrassed I know you're
embarrassed anyone who really cared
about illegal immigration wouldn't be
hiring illegal immigrants a federal
court found Donald guilty of being part
of a conspiracy to hire people illegally
well I don't know anything about
bankrupting for harmony if he had
inherited two hundred million dollars
you know weird right now selling watches
and I back you told me on my radio show
that you would release your tax return
first of all very few people listen to
your radio show that's the good news let
me just died